i run into you a lot man so how you
doing good to see you uh very nice to
see you uh congrats on this series i'm
four episodes in and the best compliment
i can give you is that uh i do a lot of
interviews and sometimes i don't
continue a series after some episodes
but i am going to finish this season
because it was real good
nice solid
that's the no [ __ ] answer you know
what i mean like i'm curious where it
goes and i want to see that you know
what i mean um
so uh i got a bunch of questions for you
and uh like a wide variety so let's
let's jump in um what the hell has the
last year or two been like for you
because i remember when you started with
like ingrid goes west and you know
you're just hoping to get a little cheat
do a little acting and now you're like
jumping from cool project to cool
project
yeah it's um
you know it's really been
a fun ride you know it's had its
difficult days
uh people don't realize that you know
when you're
when you're an actor and
you know you rap
uh you're unemployed for the first
couple of weeks and you're kind of just
waiting for the next thing but
it's just about being smart and and
you know i've been lucky to have a bunch
of
passion projects reach out to me you
know from
from
of course starting off with a passion
project with straight onto compton but
every role that i wanted to take after
that was just to show versatility and uh
i wanted it to be different from the
last and that blessed me with godzilla
you know i got to nerd out on
on kenobi recently
and so like yeah it's just been it's
been a blessing and it's just about
keeping your head down and
pushing forward and you'll end up where
you're supposed to be
um if someone has never seen anything
that you've done
what do you want them to start with
oh i mean
a straight uncomfortable always have
that place in my heart because literally
without the events of that movie i don't
exist so like you know it's key
key part in uh in my life
um so yeah obviously but i think it's
still
still anger goes west anger goes west
um
it's still just such a
it holds a place in my heart because
that was my first step on my own you
know that was my first one of like all
right we need to make the decision of
like are we going to do this what type
of actor are we gonna be
and uh you know stepping out showing
people
that i wasn't a one-trick pony and uh
really standing on my own so anger goes
west that's just that's fun long shot
long shot will be another good one you
know we uh
me and and seth that dynamic duo needs
to happen again
and uh yeah
really
swagger has pulled a lot of
a lot of emotions out of me where
you know i'm i'm starting to look at my
career differently not only you know as
a performer but as a person the topics
that we speak on with swagger you know
they hit close to home as well so i'm
hoping i'm hoping
that there's not a lot of people who
haven't seen my my works but if i had to
choose it'll be those
yeah also ingrid goes west is a really
good movie so it's it's
um when are you i asked your dad this
before and i've asked you this before
when are you and your dad gonna do
something together playing father and
son
you know he's just
he's so busy i barely know the guy uh
we know it has to happen we know it has
to be
perfect um i think the biggest thing
right now is us figuring out whether it
should be
comedy or uh dramatic
you know it's um
it's a rare thing to be able to
be on camera sparring with your old man
you know just like
there's it's just such an amazing
opportunity um that we're definitely
going to seize that moment right now i'm
just trying to get my box office numbers
up so that way when the project happens
they got to pay us both well
and uh yeah it'll happen for sure right
i also people love seeing your dad yell
at people it's like a thing i'm sure you
know that
yeah it's um you know it's
part of his makeup but what people don't
know what people don't know about my dad
is he
he laughs way more than he yells you
know the only thing that my dad
i think seriously yells at on a
continuous basis is probably the raiders
and the organization in general but
other than that yeah my dad he loves to
laugh
um he just loves to have a good time he
he's great he tells jokes like every
time we speak like you know it's just he
loves to have a good time and uh that's
that's
that's the dad i know you know people
say i'm ice cube son but like ice cube
is its own thing oshay jackson is my dad
and och jackson likes to laugh
i i totally get it um last time i saw
you you had some cool sports memorabilia
i know you're into that what have you
recently bought for yourself or been
given
um
i bought myself a
i bought myself
a
2020
los angeles lakers championship ring
because
i played two i give my all to that team
and i felt like i deserved it shout out
to genie and i also bought myself a uh a
dodgers ring too just to remind people
that los angeles was in charge of sports
during the pandemic
first of all i'm riddled just
riddled with envy and second of all i
don't even want to know what those
things cost
i can't even imagine yeah that's why i
gotta go to keep working trying to get
that swagger season two baby
[Laughter]
um i have a lot of questions for swagger
and we're about to get there but uh i am
curious are you what's the story with
denis thieves too is that actually
happening
yeah it's happening it's uh it's
happening we've uh i've already started
prepping for it
um i was just in ireland filming cocaine
bear greatest title ever but um yeah i
was in ireland and they got me a trainer
um lost 15 pounds in
28 days
so you know we're on pace for next year
for me to be right gotta get my uh my
superhero body you know so uh you know
when you when you got when you got the
right shape
your numbers go up too so you know i'm
gonna be all right
so uh so you've read the script like
this is really going oh yeah it's going
down
um it's uh
yeah christian christian
timothy's was christian's baby you know
and i don't think he christian gudegas
the director and
creator of den of thieves i don't think
he knew that
it was going to become what it is you
know you you hope that but now we're
going into a sequel and he knows that he
has to give the people what they want so
we'll see uh i can't wait for people to
see what he has me doing
uh hence the reason you have a trainer
yeah
uh well first of all congrats on on on
that that's awesome looking forward to
seeing it jumping into swagger how did
you actually get involved in this
project uh can you sort of talk about
the genesis how it came together for you
oh yeah
it's actually funny story um i was
supposed to be a different character
uh for swagger
and you know i i met with reggie rock
who
who was really
you know just a
the major piece of why i wanted to do
this was just talking with reggie
hearing what type of a man he was and
you know what he represents as
as a as a as a creator as an artist and
i really wanted to be a part of swagger
uh to be able to work with him and i was
supposed to uh play this other role but
the agents
might have pushed a little too hard and
you know in some detail because apple
was like yeah sorry bro yeah so i um i
definitely was heartbroken for a while
and i was actually on
the press tour for a long shot
when i got the call
the agents were like hey guess what
swagger's back on the table
and i was like well how was it back well
it was a season two and i was like no a
situation happened and uh they want to
offer you a new role and when they when
they told me that it was ike i knew it
was going to be a hand in glove fit
because there were so many things that i
and the character
shared you know um
before i was an actor
i was coaching my little brother's
basketball teams um you know ike in the
story is about to have his first child
and
and all the nervousness that goes into
and he has a little girl and that's the
exact same thing i was going through at
that time
and so it was it was really hand in
glove and i knew that
um when you get a role like that that
speaks so close to home all you got to
do is breathe into it and let things
happen naturally
also you are a sports fanatic so it's
not i mean this is like talking
basketball all day that's easy
you know what i mean um what did you
actually learn making the series about
like youth basketball and what goes on
behind the scenes that perhaps you
actually didn't know
um you know i've always been aware of
the shadiness of
you know
anytime you're you're dealing with
with
kids and and money is involved you know
it's usually some shady business behind
it
and so you know i was always aware but i
was excited to be able to
kind of
put my own stamp on you know getting
this story out here of what's happening
to uh these kids who are
who stop being looked at as what they
are which is young men and in women
and they're looked at as
pawns in some situations you know dollar
signs
they're they're bargaining chips it it's
it's a shady business but you know most
businesses are but nobody at that age
the age that this is happening to these
kids uh should have to deal with that
when were you excited or nervous to sign
on to something that could go for
multiple years
uh a little nervous you know it's my
first time with a with a series you know
i needed to know exactly how long i'm
signing my life away you know it's a
real hard question to ask yourself
um also will kevin durant like me
because of how obsessed i am with the
lakers is this gonna be a problem this
is gonna be an issue lakers in five but
you know it's uh it's exciting it it
it calls for new things um from my
repertoire it's it's
it's
growing with the character you always
hear about these these actors who are on
these long series and how much they're
attached to their character and watching
them grow watching them make mistakes
watching them triumph um when you do
films you don't you you still have that
arc but you get to stretch it over in a
longer amount of time and it it'll call
for some new tools of yours to be
sharpened
well i don't know i would imagine that
you were the number one on the call
sheet if not number one you were number
two depending on the day i don't know
how it goes but you are the one that i
think the young cast is looking towards
for like guidance on how to be when
you're on set did you sort of take on
that responsibility and sort of show
a lot of people who maybe haven't done
as much work like this is how you need
to do this
uh yeah you definitely you know when
you're when you're working
with
people who are are you know starting
their careers you you want to set an
example now i never
you can never
look at a group and you know just
command yourself oh well this is how you
should do it
i'm the leader and all that that noise
they'll just reject you especially you
know the my young bit of ruffians that i
worked with on this is something that
they have to
see and kind of you know put you there
and
uh you can't
if if you're if you're leading by
example you're leading them down you
know the wrong path you're doing nothing
but a disservice to all those who do
love the film industry because there's a
lot of talent that we have in this cast
in our young performers uh where they
could be great and so you got to start
off if you're going to be great you got
to start off the right way
and you know the day before
our first day of work
um together
uh we lost kobe bryant uh kobe bryant
died
literally the day before we started
filming and anybody who knows me knows
what type of influence he's had on my
life he was my hero
and you know it's hard to do a show
surrounded by basketball
and and not think about kobe bryant and
you know kobe would always lead by
example uh first one in last one out
and uh you know you
you got to be prepared to do the work
always do the work and don't let anyone
outwork you
and that's uh that's my mama mentality
that i tried to bring on set and losing
my hero just fueled that even more
yeah i uh that was a terrible day and if
i remember correctly it was a sunday
it was
it just [ __ ] terrible um
uh
sorry i got i'm in my head thinking
about you know what i mean um
so one of the things that i think that
this show
is really
one of the cool things about this show
is that it's going to show a lot of
young people who are actually playing
basketball
like what really goes on behind the
scenes without preaching to them you
know what i mean like showing the money
side showing the corruption showing all
the bs if you will and i guess could you
sort of talk about that that it's
hopefully going to be an education for
you know or for some people and
education on what really goes on
yeah you know as a um
as an actor
you want to be a part of things that
motivate
you know motor it may
motivate you to
[Music]
you know do something like
speak with loved ones more or you know
motivate you
enough to where you focus more about
your business and what's happening to
you what things to look out for what red
flags to notice
and yes i hope that swagger does that
because there's there's a a
a generation
coming out
athletes are getting better every
four or five years you know and the
numbers that they get and they produce
are getting even bigger so it is
important
for people to understand ways to protect
themselves and i hope that swagger
motivates
this young generation uh what to look
out for um
who to have in your circle how tight
that circle really needs to be
and just all around
building a
a suit of armor to have for yourself
when you deal with the real world out
there away from home
uh i obviously um as you may or may not
know am a star wars fan and there is no
way that i am not going to sit here and
ask you a question about kenobi but i
know you got to be careful with your
answers i'll just say
were you a star wars fan going in like
was this one of these things where they
called you about kenobi you're like are
you effing kidding me
yeah i'm uh
i was watching star wars before i came
down here right now
i'm a i'm a real big star wars fan and
um you know i
i had auditioned for
uh uh lando for the solo film and when i
didn't get it it like crushed me i was
like you know what i quit i'm going back
to being a writer like i'm done
and you know i was filming swagger and
my agents were like yo
um
we need you free in the next two days
noon
all right like just listen you want to
take this meeting so i took it and it
was deb lord deb shout out to lord deb
debra chow and um yeah she
gave me an opportunity of a lifetime and
it's uh god
i can't wait to talk about it so fast
i want to talk about it so bad but i
know mickey probably still has my phone
bugged
and i you know i just love my family
[Laughter]
uh i really really cannot wait to talk
to you about it yeah
can you tease were you able to touch and
use a lightsaber are you allowed to say
it
all i'm going to say is
i really am a fan of you and mcgregor
that's my boy and my man camille camille
is my dog that's my he was um he's
camille's really been a major motivation
for me when it comes to getting in shape
for dinner thieves too
because of just how jacked he got
uh for eternals and uh yeah he he's got
his his line open for me any questions
that i need
and uh yeah he's got an action figure
now because he's in the eternals and you
know i'm gonna need that he said he'll
give me
uh you know a good price for it so we'll
see how that goes i got news for you
when you're in star wars most likely
you'll also be an action figure
this is something i think you can talk
about though um
they use this really cool technology the
volume when you're making star wars and
i wanted to know what was your reaction
working with the volume technology what
impressed you what was cool about it
what's so crazy about the volume is like
you really forget like after a while you
forget
that you're just in the studio well you
know and
honestly the scariest part about it is
when they turn it off
because you'll be sitting somewhere some
cave in the middle of whatever
you got background on the volume working
around and it just you get so engulfed
in in the scene that when they turn it
off and the entire room you're in just
goes white
yeah it's it's kind of like a matrix
moment when they were when he visits the
architect it was it was a a crazy
experience and
it really would have saved a lot of
people back in the day to have that type
of technology i could just imagine you
know filming on location and these
no disrespect but these terrible places
so like you know it definitely saved a
lot of a lot of man hours
um it's it's
it's hard to explain the feeling that it
gives you walking in there the the
the abilities that
it brings as filmmakers what it just
gives us so much that normally you'd
have to be
playing pretend on a green screen or
just you know okay this looks like this
and and getting terrible descriptions
and yeah it's a it's a time saver it's a
lifesaver
and uh
god
somebody please give me more star wars
jobs
you